Is it okay to continue taking supplements, taking vitamins like vitamin D, E and healthy
vitamin, multivitamin if they're not on the supplement protocol, the DES, the EES.
So make sure you're taking a, let me type this out, okay?
So make sure you're taking, when you talk about your supplements, I do have a video on this
but your vitamin E. So vitamin E has four inner particles and four outer shells so a lot of
the vitamin E that you buy at the store is going to be alpha to cough or alpha beta to cough
for all or alpha gamma to cough for all. So the outer shells of the vitamin E are called
pocophyrus and they are good for different things and understand when vitamin E, when all
these supplements were discovered, they were discovered depending upon the microscopy they
had at the time so all they saw was the outer shell and that was called vitamin E. Well
that is the first outer shell that's called alpha to cough or all. So there's four outer shells,
alpha beta, gamma, delta to cough or all. Well then later as the microscopy has improved they
found those other outer shells and then they also found that it's actually has four inner shells.
The four inner shells are called the toco-treatals. So the toco-treat-in-alls are the really the
component of vitamin E that is most important for your heart, most important for your vessels.
The delta toco-treat-all is the most important for your blood vessels. It is also the most important
for your cancer. So a lot of times when you go to the store and you buy vitamin E you're really
getting alpha to cough for all or alpha to cough for all which is just the outer, the first outer shell
which is really pretty worthless. So you want to get a vitamin E that doesn't just say alpha
or alpha delta or mix to cough for all. You want one that has the toco-treat-in-alls as well. The most
important is the delta toco-treat-all. That's why we use the APOP-E, we private labeled the APOP-E
because it has a full spectrum of the toco-for-alls and the toco-treat-all is mostly what to cough for us.
So that's really important. The same thing goes through true for multivitamins.
A lot of the multivitamins out there have synthetic products in there. That's why we would rather
have you just do greens instead of a multivitamid. And also most multivitamins have a lot of methyl groups.
So methylcobolamide and methyl tetrahedral late can function to turn off gene so we don't want
excess methyl groups with a cancer patient. So I'd rather have you just do the greens product instead
of a multivitamid. Why is G okay on my protocol? But dairy fed on my tumor because G doesn't have
the same products as just regular dairy. It is still dairy but it's refined and I've never made
G but you know, patients have made G and it doesn't have the exact same products as dairy. So
if somebody's like, I really want to have something different on my toes that the G can be an option.
If you're going on a trip and you want to bring your right machine, is it okay to put it
through the X-ray machine at the airport? Yes, it is. That won't harm it if I've done it.
Dozens of times. Could acupuncture help with their opathy? Possibly, yeah, it's worth a
give it a try. Yeah, there are some acupuncture results that are real good that might be able to help
with their opathy as well. Another thing that can help with their opathy is vitamin B6. So B6 is
often used for their opathy. That can be also a help. So consider that. My old drive protocol
I am pro-way had a detox program and I do not see the detox plan pro-way problem in the new material set
and uploaded. Can I do the old I am pro-way detox program? It felt so good. You can try it just be
careful. You're not blowing the fuses. Also, you can go into your right settings into the alphabetical
list in the folders. You can scroll down to see the I am pro-way folder and it's probably in there.
Can you spell that for vitamin E? So the cough are all right there with a total triadolus
of the paper E.